we're going we're going it's going hi
guys my name is grace helbig if you
don't know no you know you're like she's
different now
mamrie Hart and I have ants that are
very close friends and if you did not
know that congratulations
your life is now about to get a little
bit bad and I could force themselves
onto our channel and into our live shows
and because I got blackout drunk in my
family holiday party this year and my
aunt told me I did some weird [ __ ]
I'm not waited to upload their video to
my youtube channel they want to tell you
about their New Year's resolutions they
talk about a couple of them on this
channel and then the restaurant memories
channel I don't know just watch it I
don't know good one you want one
is it one it's one it's one hello look
where we are
I feel like we're on the Food Network
cooking show look at us make me some
brown butter so I saw us with say oh oh
it's gonna smell II invite me over for
dinner who Alyx finish mili she's the
judge on short who always looks like
she's smiling afford oh she's the one
that makes direct eye contact when she
eats the food yeah she got oh my god I
heard that's really good on dates like
you can see if you have chemistry if
when you eat you just go like a Blowfish
they get his dad hit to hit the skin you
don't know us what I mean what rock you
live under what do you pay for rent I am
marucho no relation Asian so stop
sending me messages saying you saw me at
the Comedy Cellar oh my god has a
basement in my house you don't you out
of that flooded hurricane sandy got me
good there was no haha' in that cellar
no but at least you got a cèlle
and were able to move and I was able to
move yeah and I am clitoris tremble I am
mainly thorns and I yeah I'm just so
proud of those too me too
you know 2016 well a big one Wow
everybody had a tough day I mean 365 um
well I Barry well librarians we work in
a library maybe you've heard of it this
is when you used to have to go to an
actual location to get a book to get
some books and not just get on your
little Kindle do a couple slippy swiping
look I got these new glasses that's
really good
thank you but I feel like I'm in a wrap
music video Oh me turns on a light to
make us look dewy it looks like you got
peppermint lifesavers in your eyeball do
I look like I'm at the hostess stand of
a diner I'm gonna go back to my old
glasses okay I can't see anything
you should get LASIK what you know why I
love these glasses I like it that it has
two built-in armor Alton eyebrows I
never have to fill my eyebrows and ever
you'll save so much for the new year to
style icons coward LG Nam don't allies
deviled eggs sour deviled eggs Ernie
from Bert and Ernie you know what do I
look a little bit which ones Ernie
new years we had a crazy New Year's
oh my god I'm surprised we even remember
it we are not allowed back into ChaCha's
Mexican restaurant no not to the point
where they have a picture of us at the
front desk not so much a picture as a
caricature drawing a buck I mean nicely
they put me on a jet ski and you want a
horse thank God we stole some stools we
did steal a couple stool we also I like
to say stole some pots because you're
way too loved us until we started
throwing talk Oh Fred loved us until the
fajitas went although I had him eating
out of the palm of my hand literally
like a horse at a feeding zoo he was
eating just a thing of refried beans out
of my hand he loved it we're here today
because every year mm-hmm we feel like
it's very important that you should try
to better yourself oh cool Oprah's been
better in herself for 70 years of
something like red she loves bread god
she look I wish I could find a man to
love me the way the Oprah loves bread
did I just make a quote you did you did
a Twitter oh my god you just needed time
we did guys follow her on Twitter let me
I was at Hearst Twitter so we thought
that we would share with you yeah all
resolutions because then were like held
accountable this is a big one okay only
Google George Clooney once a day oh that
is a big one for you she broke her modem
one day when he got that new
relationship with a mall she broke her
mold it was a rough day
let's just say my mouse walked toward
her then a mouse in a clinical study for
mesh whoa look I love George Clooney
I think he's classically handsome I'm
happy he finally settled down but I'm
not gonna say I don't wish it was with
me of course you know what always tastes
better what things were sort and pepper
oh wait it again just tweeted again oh
my god you like did my verified you're
verifying quite a feud told I got it
George Clooney on Twitter you can follow
me on Twitter oh my god can i DM him my
moods your noodles okay here's mine um
walk to the back of Spencer's gift shop
once oh my god you've been talking about
this for a decade where's back there
speaking of nude sick she possibly don't
want to look at it I feel like a pervert
when I get close like I get to the
machine yeah the orb with all the lasers
inside that yeah oh that feels like
you're like are we going back to the
future you can get past all the
marijuana paraphernalia yep you can get
past to all the I mean apparently kids
still it's the Pink Floyd I guess and
then kisses doc my cataracts go crazy
and it's like I mean you get the LASIK I
don't want to get the LASIK eyes I think
we should have a night okay where I make
a big old pot of woobin penis pasta and
we both wear corduroy oh my god we
watched Jurassic Park oh my god 2017
it's light it up okay here's my last one
how many resolutions have don't do this
mm-hmm don't do that
this is a do this oh go out there and do
this right now all right what is it
learn the drums huh well you know I have
a huge crush on Phil :
oh my god there's nothing I find sexier
than a man who can be a lead singer
while he's a drummer I mean that is a
very specific I can't I got here I was
thinking about like he's doing a
comeback tour I love an activity that
you can do while you sit down
oh me too like a crossword on a toilet
Oh Oh this year I said you know what
stop just having questions on all these
drums
you better pick up the sticks and go out
there and one woman oh hey look at you
you already know what you're doing
really well yeah we should get you rock
band you know that game and you can play
them and then not like real drunk not
real out
I'm straw a store across love in my own
body because I love the drum yep but I
hate the noise what's your last one
Margaret Cho okay well I got two of them
that I like and then maybe they can
happen at the same time oh um so what a
one is I want to do a handstand okay
okay not like yoga just like I just
wanted to a handstand
I hate yoga me oh yeah let me pay you so
I can stretch salute the Sun here what's
up son good boy
yeah down the dog I'm allergic a dander
all right so dancing I'll hold your feet
if you need to okay I've been doing some
risk weights lately oh yeah I've seen
you I was wondering why you were wearing
such baggy sweatshirts does Margaret
Show have doughnuts um haha not her red
wrist weights where will you sleep
you do have night tremors I do because
I'm the Billy Blanks of slumber we had
to share a bed one time we weren't
traveling and uh
the second room got canceled I woke up
with so many bruises I'm sorry I to say
I fell down the stairs my last one is
very similar to your sort of meat or
kiss Liam Neeson I think you should kiss
him I think I should kiss him I think
you were taken by that man Oh
take him to my bed well but then we need
to spend the night at his house so you
don't kick him in the face but I feel
like he can defend himself he's very
strong he always been old I think so I
think he was born like 70 okay really
should just like get a security system
in this house cuz all of his family
keeps getting taken I can't but you
can't watch the Jurassic Park oh I love
violence
I hate don't you store animals thank you
so much those are resolution okay and
make sure you guys hold us accountable
tell us on the Twitter tweet us in the
comments leave us an emoticon but not
the eggplants cuz that's just vile Oh
someone send me an eggplant with a
little squirt Oh
perverts I almost threw up and you know
if you want to hear more about our
resolutions you can find out the rest of
them over uncle' Doris's nieces channel
of Hungary's channel and the really
spicy oh they're so spicy I think I need
a gallon of milk
why because I help school your mouth Oh
watch both ends Oh goodbye
boy I know are you often a little with
usual how do I get it all just want to
get it all how do I get it all okay I
push it to get it off and then boom I've
read Moby Dick no big deal yeah right
gotta smell the paper touch it you gotta
smell the paper go and get your
fingerprints on it but now wash your
hands before you washing hands loop or
check out our books because we're very
proud of our collection extensive
cleanliness first tráfico expensive
beautiful every week